The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So it's good to
remind ourselves why
we are doing what
we are doing today.
So we've seen that
in a number of cases,
we look at something like
the coexistence line of gas
and liquid that terminates
at the critical point.
And that in the vicinity
of this critical point,
we see various thermodynamic
quantities and correlation
functions that have
properties that
are independent of the
materials that are considered.
So this led to this
concept of universality,
and we were able to justify
that by looking at properties
of this statistical field.
And we ended up with
[INAUDIBLE] normalization
group procedure,
which classified
the different universality
classes according
to the number of components
of the order parameter,
the thing that categorizes
the coexisting phases,
and the dimensionality of space.
And that, in
particular something
like a liquid-gas system, would
correspond to n equals to 1.
Another example that
would correspond to that
would be, for example,
a mixture of two metals
in a binary alloy.
You can have the
different components mixed
or phase separated
from each other.
So the normalization group
method gave us the reason
for there is this
universality, but we
found that calculating
the exponent
was a hard task coming
from four dimensions.
So the question is, given that
these models or these numbers,
the singularities
here are universal,
can we obtain them from
a different perspective?
And so let's say we are
focused on this kind
of liquid-gas system,
which belong to this n
equals to 1 universality class.
So we can try to imagine
the simplest model
that we can try to
solve that belongs
to that universality class.
And again, maybe thinking
in terms of a binary alloy,
something that has
two possible values.
In the liquid-gas,
it could be cells
that are either empty or
filled with a particle.
And so this binary model
is this Ising model,
where, at each
side of a lattice,
we put a variable
that is minus plus 1.
And so the idea is, again, if
I take any one of these Ising
models and I
coarse-grain them, I
will end up with the
same statistical field,
and it would have the
same universality class.
But if I make a sufficiently
simple version of these models,
maybe I can do something else
and solve them in a manner
that these critical
behaviors can come up
in an easier fashion.
So let's say we are interested
in two dimensions or three
dimensions.
I can draw two
dimensions better.
We draw a square lattice.
On each side of it, we put
one of these variables.
And in order to
capture this tendency
that there is a possibility
of coexistence where
you have patches that are
made of liquid or gas,
or made of copper or
zinc in our binary alloy,
we need to have a tendency for
things that are close to each
other to be in the same
state so that we can capture
by a Hamiltonian, which is a
sum over nearest neighbors, that
gives an enhanced weight
if they are parallel.
And whatever that
coupling is, once it
is rescaled by kT, this
combination, the energy divided
by kT, we can parametrize
by a dimensionless number k.
And calculating the
behavior of the system
as a function of
temperature, as the strength
of the coupling in
this simplified model,
amounts to calculating
the partition function
as a function of a parameter
k, which is a sum over,
if I'm in a system that
has n sites all to the n
configurations, of a weight that
tries to make variables that
are next to each other
to be in the same state.
So clearly, what
is captured here
is a competition
between energy-- energy
would like everybody to
be in the same state--
versus entropy.
Entropy wants to have
different states at each site.
So you'll have a factor
of 2 per site as opposed
to everybody being aligned,
which is essentially one state.
And so that
competition potentially
could lead you to a phase
transition between something
that has coexistent at low
temperature and something that
is disordered at
high temperatures.
So now we have just
recast the problem.
Rather than having a partition
function which was a functional
integral over all configurations
of the statistical field,
I have to do this
partition function, which
is finite number
of configurations,
but it's still an
interacting theory.
I cannot independently move
the variable at each site.
So the question is,
are there approaches
by which I can calculate this?
And one set of approaches
is to start with a limit
that I can solve and
start expanding on that.
And these expansions that are
analogous to the perturbation
expansions that we
learned in 8.333
about interacting
systems, in this case
are usually called
series expansions.
One would perform
them on a lattice.
Now, I kind of hinted at
two limits of the problem
that we know exactly
what is happening,
and those lead to two
different series expansions.
One of them is the
low-temperature expansions.
And here the idea
is that I know what
the system is doing
at T equals to 0.
At T equals to 0, I have to
find the configuration that
minimizes the energy.
T equals to 0 is also equivalent
to k going to infinity.
I have to find a state
that maximizes this weight,
and that's obviously the
case where all of the spins
are either plus or minus.
So all sigma i equals to
plus 1 or all sigma i equals
to minus 1.
But for the sake of
doing one or the other,
let's imagine that
they are all plus
and that I am solving the
problem for the generalization
of square cube to
d-dimensional lattice.
After all, we were doing
d dimensions in general.
So in d dimensions, each
spin will have d neighbors.
And so if I ask, what
is the weight that I
will get at 0 temperature,
essentially each spin
would have d factors of k.
So the weight that I would get
at T equals to 0-- let's call
that Z of T equals to 0--
is simply e to the dNk.
There are N sites.
Each one of them has d
neighbors in d dimensions.
Of course, each one of
them has 2d neighbours,
but then I have to count the
number of neighbors per site.
So basically, this bond is
shared by two neighbors,
so half of it
contributes to this site.
And there are two possibilities.
So the partition function at
T equals to 0 is simply this.
It's just the contribution
of the two ground states.
Now, we are interested in
the limit where T goes to 0.
So at T equals to 0, I
know what is happening.
Now, what I will get
as I allow temperature
to be larger, at some
cost I am able to flip
some of these spins from,
say, the plus to minus.
And I will get, in this case,
islands of negative spin
in sea of plus.
And these islands will
give a contribution
that is going to be
exponentially small in k
and something to do with the
bonds that I have broken.
And by broken, I mean gone
from the high energy, well,
highly satisfied plus-plus state
to the unsatisfied plus-minus
state, in fact, 2k times
number of broken bonds.
So we can very easily write the
first few terms in this series.
So let's make a list of
the excitation, or island
that I can make,
how many ways I can
make this, which I
will call degeneracy,
and the number of broken bonds.
So clearly, the
simplest thing that I
can do in a sea of pluses
is to make one island, which
is simply a site that
has been previously plus
and now has gone
to become a minus.
And this particular excitation
can occur any one of N places
if I have a lattice
of size N. And I'm
going to ignore any corrections
that I may have from the edges.
If you want you can do that,
and that'd be more precise.
But let's focus,
essentially, on things
that are proportional to N.
Then how many bonds
have I broken?
You can see that
in two dimensions,
I have broken four bonds.
In three dimensions,
it would have been six.
So essentially, it
is twice the number
of dimensions that
is taking place.
And so the
contribution to energy
is going to be e
to the minus 2d.
And I went from
plus k to minus k,
so in fact, I would
have to multiply by 2k.
Now, the next thing
that I can do,
the lowest energy excitation
is to put two minuses that
are next to each other
in this sea of pluses.
OK?
Now, you can see that
in two dimension,
I can orient this pair
along the x-direction
or along the y-direction.
And in general, there would be d
directions, so I would have dN.
Roughly, you would say
that the number of bonds
that you have
broken is twice what
you had before if the
two were separate.
But there is this
thing in between
that is now actually
a satisfied bond.
So you can convince
yourself that, actually,
if the two of them
were separate,
these two minus excitations,
I would have 4d.
But because I joined them,
essentially I have 2d minus 1
from each one of them,
and there's two of those.
And of course, the
next lowest excitation
would indeed be to
have two minuses that
have no site, are totally
separate from each other.
And the contribution--
the number of these,
well, this is
something to count.
The first one can
any one of N places.
The next one can be in any one
of N minus 2d minus 1 places.
It cannot be on the same
one, and it cannot be in any
of the 2d neighbors.
And I should have
double counting,
so there is a factor of 2 here.
And the cost of this is simply
twice that, so this is 4d.
So if I want to start writing
a partition function expanded
beyond what I have
at 0 temperature,
what I would have
would be 2e to the dNk.
There's zero temperature
contribution.
I would have 1 plus N e
to the minus 4dk plus dN
e to the minus 4 2d minus 1 k.
And then from the other
one that I have written,
N N minus 2d minus 1
over 2e to the minus 8dk.
And I can keep going and
adding higher and higher order
terms of the series.
OK?
OK.
Once I have the
partition function,
I can start calculating
the energy, which
would be minus d log Z
with respect to d beta.
What is beta?
Well, I said that this
factor is something like 1
over kT, which is beta and J.
So assuming that I
have a fixed energy
and I'm changing temperature,
and the variations of k
are reflecting the
inverse temperature beta,
then I can certainly
multiply here a J and a J,
which is a constant.
And all I need to
do is to take a J d
by dk of log of the expression
that I have above there.
OK?
So let's take the log
of that expression.
I have log of 2
plus dNk from here.
And then I have log of
1 plus terms in a series
that I have
calculated perturbity.
Now, log of 1 plus
a small quantity I
can always expand
as a small quantity
minus x squared over 2.
You may worry whether or
not, with N ultimately
going to infinity, this
is a small quantity.
Neglecting that
for the time being,
if I look at this as log
of 1 plus a small quantity,
from here I would get N e
to the minus 4dk plus dN
e to the minus 4 2d minus
1 k plus N N minus 1
minus 2d over 2e to the
minus 8dk, and so forth.
But then remember
that log of 1 plus x
is x minus x squared over 2 plus
x cubed over 3, and so forth.
So if x is my small
quantity, I will
have a correction, which
is minus x squared over 2.
Let's just do it
for this first term.
I will get minus N squared
over 2e to the minus 8dk,
and there will be a whole
bunch of higher-order terms.
OK?
Now, where am I going with this?
Ultimately, I want to calculate
various quantities that
are extensive in the sense that
they are proportional to N,
and when I divide by
N I will get something
like energy per site.
So if I do that, I have to
divide this whole thing by N,
I can see that here
I have a term that
is log T divided by N. In
the N goes to infinity limit,
it's a term that has order
of 1 over N I can neglect.
But all of these other
terms are proportional to N.
And when I divide by N, I
can drop these factors of N.
Well, except that I
have a couple of terms
that, if I had
left by themselves,
potentially could have
been order of N squared.
I have N squared over
2, but fortunately, you
can see that it
cancels out over there.
Now, the reason this
happens, and also
the reason this
series is legitimate,
is because we already did
something very similar to that
in 8.333 when we were doing
these cumulant expansions.
And when we were doing
these cumulant expansions,
we obtained the series for,
then, the grand partition
function, which was a
whole bunch of terms.
But when we took the log, only
the connected terms survived.
And the connected
terms were the things
that, because they
had a center of mass,
were giving you a factor that
was proportional to volume.
And here you expect that
ultimately everything
that I will get here, if I
calculate, let's say, log Z
properly and then
divide by N, it
should be something
that is order of 1.
It shouldn't be order
of N, or N cubed,
or any of these other terms.
So essentially, the purpose of
all of these higher-order terms
is really to subtract
off things such as this
that would arise in
the counting when
we look at islands
and excitations that
are disconnected.
So I could have something right
here, something right here.
So this would be,
essentially, a product
of the contributions of
these different islands.
As long as they are disconnected
from some term in the series,
there would be a subtraction
that would get rid of that
and would ensure that these
additional factors of N,
because I can move each island
over the entire lattice,
would disappear.
So I have this series,
and now I can basically
take the derivatives.
So I have minus J,
and I take d by dk
of the various terms
that have survived.
The first one is d.
So dJ is essentially
the energy pair site
that I would have
at 0 temperature.
I have strength J, deeper site.
And then the
excitations will start
to reduce that and correct that.
And so from here, I would get
minus 4d e to the minus 4dk.
From here, I would get
minus 4 2d minus 1 d
e to the minus 4 2d minus 1 k.
The N-squared terms disappeared.
So I would have
2d plus 1 over 2.
But then it gets multiplied by
8d when I take a derivative.
So I will get plus 4d 2d
plus 1 e to the minus 8dk,
and so forth in the series.
OK?
So these terms that
are subtraction,
you can see that you
can really easily
connect to these
primary excitations.
If you like, this
term corresponds
to taking two of these and
colliding them with each other.
They cannot be on
top of each other.
They cannot be
next to each other.
And so there is a
subtraction because a number
of configurations
are not allowed.
So this is, in
some sense, a kind
of expansion in
these excitations
and the interactions
among these excitations.
OK?
Now presumably,
what is happening
is that at very low
temperature, you
are going to get these
individual simple excitations
with a little bit of
interaction between them.
As you increase the temperature,
the size of these islands
will get bigger and bigger.
They start to merge
into each other.
Configurations
that you would see
will be big islands in a sea.
And presumably, the
size of these islands
is some measure of
the correlation length
that you have in this
low temperature state.
Eventually, this
correlation length
will hit the size of the system.
And then the starting point,
that you had a sea of pluses
and you're exciting around
it, it is no longer valid.
If you like, that vacuum
state has become unstable,
and this series, the way
that we are constructing it,
ceases to go beyond that point.
OK?
So let's take another step.
If I've calculated the
energy, I could also
calculate the heat
capacity, which is d by dT.
Actually, I expect the heat
capacity to be extensive also,
so I'll divide by
N. So I will look
at the heat capacity per site.
I know that the natural
units of heat capacity
are kB, which has dimensions of
energy divided by temperature.
So I divide by kB.
So here I will have kBT.
But then I notice that kBT,
these are related inversely
to K, capital K. It is J over
K. So I can write this as J
over K, and d by d-- 1 over K
will give me a minus K squared.
I will have a factor of 1
over J, and the 1 over J
actually cancels this
factor of J here.
So all I need to do-- well,
actually, let me write
it, J d by dK of this E over N.
So the expression
that I have above, I
have to take another
derivative with respect
to K multiplied by
minus K squared over J.
The J's cancel
out, and so I will
have a series that will be
proportional to K squared.
Good, I made everything
dimensionless.
And then the first term
that will contribute
will be 16 d squared e to
the minus 4dK, from here.
And from here, I will
get 16 2d minus 1
squared d e to the
minus 4 2d minus 1 K.
And from here, I would
get minus 32d 2d plus 1 e
to the minus 8dK,
and then so forth.
OK?
So you can see that
this is something
that is a kind of
mechanical process,
that in the '40s and
'50s, without even
the need for any computers,
people could sit down and draw
excitations,
provide these terms,
and go to higher and higher
order terms in the series.
Now, the reason that they
were going to do this
is that the
expectation that if I
look at this heat capacity
as a function of something
like temperature, which is e
to the 1 over k, for example,
then it starts at 0.
And if we get corrections from
these higher and higher order
terms in the
series-- I calculated
the first few--
I don't know what
will happen if I were to include
higher and higher order terms.
But my expectation is that,
say, at least at some point
when this expansion from
low temperature breaks down,
I will have a divergence, let's
say, of the heat capacity.
Or maybe I calculated
susceptibility
or some other
quantity, and I expect
to have some singularity.
And maybe by looking and fitting
more terms in the series,
one can guess what the
exponent and the location
of the singularity is.
So you can see that,
actually in this case,
the natural variable that
I am expanding is not K,
but e to the minus 2dK--
sorry, e to the minus 2K
because each excitation will
have a number of broken bonds
that I have to calculate.
Each one of them makes a
contribution like this.
So maybe we can call
this our new variable.
And we have a series that
has a function of this
or some other variable,
has a singularity.
Actually, you should be
able to, first of all,
convince yourself that the
nature of the singularity
is not modified by any
mapping that is analytical
at the point of the singularity.
So if the heat capacity
as a function of k
has a particular divergence,
as a function of u
it will have exactly
the same divergence.
In particular, we expect
that as u approaches
some critical value,
the kinds of functions
that we are interested have a
behavior, a singular behavior,
that is something like
1 minus u over uC.
Let's say for the
heat capacity, I
would expect some kind of
a singularity such as this.
If I had a pure
function such as this
and I constructed an
expansion in u, what do I get?
I will get 1 plus
alpha u over uC
plus alpha alpha plus 1
over 2 uC squared u squared,
and so forth.
It's just a binary
series expanded.
The l term in the series would
be alpha alpha plus 1 alpha
plus l minus 1 divided by l
factorial-- that's actually
2 factorial-- uC to the power
of l u to the l and so forth.
OK?
Now, typically, one of the
ways that you look at series
and decide whether it's a
singular convergent series
or what the behavior
is is to look
at the ratio of
subsequent terms.
So let's say that when
I calculated my function
C as a function of
u, I constructed
a series whose terms
had coefficients
that I will call al.
OK?
So here, if you had
exactly this series,
you would say that the ratio
al divided by al minus 1
is essentially the ratio of
one of these factors compared
to the previous one.
And every time you add
one of these factors,
you add a term that is like
this alpha plus l minus 1,
l factorial compared to l minus
1 factorial has a factor of l,
and then you have uC.
And I can rewrite this as uC
inverse, l divided by l is 1,
and then I have minus 1
minus alpha divided by l.
OK?
So a pure divergence of the
form that I have over here
would predict that the
ratio of subsequent terms
would be something like this.
And presumably, if
you go sufficiently
high in the series, in order
to reproduce this divergence
you must have that form.
So what you could do
as a test is to plot,
for your actual series, what
the ratio of these terms
is as a function of 1 over l.
So you can start with the ratio
of the second to first term.
You would be at 1/2.
Then you would go 1/3,
then you would go 1/4,
you would have
1/5, and basically
you would have a set of points.
And you would plot
what the location
is for the first term in
the series, the next term
in the series, the next term
in the series, and so forth.
And if you are
lucky, you would be
able to then pass
a straight line
at large distances
in the series.
And the intercept of
that extrapolated line
would be your inverse
of the singular point.
And the slope of
this line would give
you 1 minus alpha or
minus 1 minus alpha.
OK?
So there is really, a
priori, not much reason
to hope that that will
happen because you
can say that if I look at the
series that is A 1 minus u
over uC to the minus alpha, plus
I add an analytic part, which
is sum p equals 1 to,
say, 52 of bl u to the l.
For any bl in this function has
exactly the same singularity
as the original one.
And yet the first 52
terms in the series,
because of this additional
analytical form,
have nothing to do with
the eventual singularity.
They're going to
be massing that.
So there is no reason for you
to expect that this should work.
But when people do this, and
they find that, let's say,
for d equals to 2 up to
some jumping up and down,
they get a reasonable
straight line.
And the exponent that they get
would correspond very closely
to the alpha of 0, which is the
logarithmic divergence that one
gets.
So this is, for d equals to
2, and then they repeat it,
let's say, for d
equals to 3, they
get a different set of points.
OK?
Maybe not perfectly
on a straight line,
but you can still extrapolate
and conclude from that
that you'll have an alpha
which is roughly 0.11 when
d equals to 3,
which is quite good.
So for some reason or
other, these lattice models
are kind of sufficiently
simple that,
in an appropriate
expansion, they
don't seem to give you
that much of a problem.
And so people have gone
and calculated series,
let's say, this was
in '50s and '60s,
just by drawing things on hand.
And maybe some
primitive computers,
you can go to order of
20 terms in this series,
and then extrapolate exponents
for various quantities.
OK?
But it's not as simple as that.
And the reason I calculated
the first three terms for you
was to show you that what I
told you here was clearly a lie.
Why is that?
Because of the three terms that
I explicitly calculated for you
in that series, the
third one is negative.
Right?
So clearly, if I
were to plot that,
I will get something over here.
Right?
So what's going gone there
is a different issue.
And people have developed
kind of methodologies and ways
to look at series and
guess what is going on
and yet continue to
extract exponents.
So one potential origin
for alternating signs--
and any series that has a
divergence such as the one
that I have indicated for you
will have, eventually, signs
that need to be positive--
has to do with the following.
Let's say if I take a series,
which is 1 over 1 minus z/2.
OK?
This is a very nice series.
It's 1 plus 0/2 z
squared/4, z cubed/8.
You could apply this
ratio test to this series
and conclude that you
have a linear divergence.
Now, suppose I multiply
that by 1 over 1
plus z squared, which
is a function that's
perfectly well-behaved
as a function of z.
Yet if I multiply it here, I
will get 1 minus z squared plus
z to the fourth
minus z to the sixth.
And what it does is
it kind of distorts
what is happening over here.
Actually, in this
series you can see
it kind of becomes ill-defined
when z is of order of 1.
It changes the signs, et cetera.
But the function itself has a
perfectly good singularity that
appears at z equals to 2.
And starting from
an expansion from 0,
there should be no
problems along the line
until you hit z of 2.
What is the reason for
these alternating signs?
It is because you should be
looking at the complex z plane.
And in the complex z plane, you
have poles at plus and minus i
which are located closer to
the origin than you have at 2.
So basically, your
series will start
to have problems by
the time you hit here,
and that problem is reflected
in the alternating behavior.
It's also showing up over there.
Yet it has nothing to do with
going along the real axis
and encountering the
singularity that you are after.
OK?
So one thing that you
can do is to say, well,
who said I should
use z as my variable?
Maybe I can choose some
other function v of z.
OK?
And then when I choose
the appropriate thing,
the singularity on the real
axis will be pushed to v of 2.
But maybe I chose appropriate
function of v of z
such that the
other singularities
are pushed very far away so that
the first singularity that I
encounter is over here.
OK?
And it turns out that
if you take this series
over here and rather than
working with e to the minus k,
we recast things in terms
of tanh K-- let's call
that v-- which is e to
the K plus e to the minus
K-- well actually, tanh
K I can also write as e
to the 2K minus 1
e to the 2K plus 1.
I mean, it's just
a transformation.
So I can replace
e to the minus 2K
with some function v,
substitute for u in that series,
and I will have a
different function
as an expansion in powers of v.
And once people do that,
same thing happens as here.
You'll find a function that
all of its terms are, in fact,
positive, and the things that
I mentioned to you over here
were applied.
After such transformation,
you get very nice behaviors.
OK?
So there seems to
be some guesswork
into finding the
appropriate transformation.
There are other methods
for dealing with series
and extracting
singularities called
Pade approximants, et cetera,
which I won't go into.
But there are kind of, again,
clever mathematical tricks
for extracting singularity
out of series such as this.
OK?
So I'll tell you shortly
why this tanh K is really
a good expansion factor.
It turns out that
for Ising models,
it's actually the
right expansion factor
if we go to the other
limit of high temperatures.
OK?
So basically, now at
T going to infinity,
you would say that sigma
i is minus or plus 1
with equal probability.
As T goes to
infinity, this factor
that encodes the tendency of
spins to be next to each other
has been scaled to 0,
so I know exactly what
is going on at
infinite temperature.
Basically, at each site, I
have an independent variable
that is decoupled
from everything else.
So I can start expanding around
that for, say, the partition
function.
Let's think of it for
a general spin system.
So I will write it
as a trace over,
let's say, if I have Potts
model rather than two values,
I would have K values
of something like e
to the minus beta
H, again, trying
to be reasonably general.
And the idea is that as you
go to infinite temperature,
beta goes to 0,
and this function
you can expand in a series 1
minus beta H plus beta squared
H squared over 2, and so forth.
Now, the trace of
1 is essentially
summing over all
possible states.
Let's say the two
states that you
would have for the Ising
model or however many
that you have for Potts models
at each site independently.
So that can give me
some partition function
that I will call Z0.
It is simply 2 to the
n for the Ising model.
But once I factor
that, you can see
that the rest of the
terms in the series
can be regarded as expectation
values of this Hamiltonian
with respect to this
weight in which all
of the degrees of
freedom are treated
as independent,
unconstrained variables.
And of course, the thing
that I'm interested
is log of the
partition function.
And so that will
give me log of Z0,
and then I have the
log of this series.
And then you can see that that
series is a generating function
for the moments of
the Hamiltonian.
So its log will be the
generating function
for the cumulant, so H
to the l 0, the cumulant.
So the variance at
the second order
and appropriate cumulant
at higher orders.
OK?
So let's try to calculate this
for the Ising model, where
my minus beta H is K sum
over i, j sigma i sigma j.
OK?
Then at the lowest
order, what do I get?
The average of beta
H is K sum over i,
j average of sigma i sigma
j with this zeroed weight.
But as I emphasized,
at zeroed weight,
every site independently
can be plus or minus.
Because of the
independence, I can do this.
And then since each site
has equal probability to be
plus or minus, its average is 0.
So basically, this will be 0.
OK?
So the first thing that
can happen in that series--
if I go to the next order.
So at next order, beta H
squared would involve K
squared sum over i, j K, l
sigma i sigma j sigma K sigma l.
And I have to take
an average of this,
which means that I have to
take an average of something
like this.
OK.
And you would say, well,
again, everything is 0.
Well, there is one case
where it won't be 0--
if these two pairs
are identical.
Right?
So this is going to give me
K squared sum over pair i,
j being the same as K, l.
Then I will get,
essentially, sigma i
squared sigma j squared.
Sigma i squared is 1.
Sigma j squared is 1.
So basically, I will get 1.
And this is going
to give me K squared
times the number of bonds.
OK?
So you can see that
I can start thinking
of this already graphically.
Because what I did over here,
I said that on my lattice
this sum says you pick
one sigma i sigma j.
If I were to pick the other
sigma i sigma j over here,
the average would be 0.
I am forced to put two of
them on top of each other.
If I go to three,
there is no way
that I can draw a
diagram that involves
three pairs in which every
single site occurs twice,
which is what I need.
Because a single site appearing
by itself or three times
will give me sigma i cubed
is the same as sigma i.
It will average to 0.
So the next thing that I can
do is to go to level four.
At the level of
four, I can certainly
do something like this.
I can put all four of
them on top of each other,
and then I get a K to
the fourth contribution.
Or I could put a pair
here, and if they're here,
for log Z that would be
unacceptable because that will
get subtracted out when
I calculate the variance.
It's not a connected piece.
It's a disconnected piece.
But I could have
something like this,
two of them turned like this.
So that's four.
But really, the one that is
nontrivial and interesting
is when I do something
like this, like a square.
So I go here sigma 1
sigma 2, sigma 2 sigma 3.
That sigma 2 has been
repeated twice and becomes
sigma 2 squared and goes away.
Sigma 3 sigma 4, sigma
3 repeated twice,
sigma 4 repeated twice, sigma
1 repeated twice, [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
So you can see that
this kind of expansion
will naturally lead you
into an expansion in terms
of loops on a lattice.
So the natural form of
high temperature expansions
are these closed
strings or loops,
if you like, that you have
to draw on the lattice.
Now, it's also clear
that the thing that
goes between two sites, that I'm
indicating by K, in all cases
is likely to be
repeated by putting
more and more things
on top of each other
without modifying the effect.
So I can go here to 4 and things
like actually 3 and things
like that.
So basically, you can
see that I should really
do a summation over the
contribution of 2, 4, et
cetera all on top of
each other, or 1, 3,
5 on top of each other, and
call them new variables.
So when we were doing the
cluster expansion for particles
interacting, we
encountered this thing
that we thought v was a
good variable to expand it.
But then because
of these repeats,
we decided that e to
the minus beta v minus 1
was a good variable
to expand it.
So a similar thing happens here.
And for the Ising model,
it is a very natural thing
to recast this series in
a slightly different way.
You see that the contribution
of each bond to the partition
function, and by a bond I mean
a pair of neighboring sites,
is a factor e to the
K sigma i sigma j.
OK?
Now, since we are dealing
with binary variables,
this product, sigma i sigma
j, can only take two values.
It's either plus K
or minus K depending
on where things are
aligned or misaligned.
So I can indicate
the binary nature
of this in the
following fashion.
I can write this as e to the
K plus e to the minus K over 2
plus sigma i sigma j e to the K
minus e to the minus K over 2.
So that when I'm dealing
with sigma sigma being plus,
I add those two factors.
e to the minus K's disappear.
I will get e to the
K. When I'm dealing
with this thing to the minus,
the e to the K's disappear,
and I will get e to
the minus K. So it's
correct rewriting
of that factor.
The first term you,
of course, recognize
as the hyperbolic cosine
of K, the second one
as the hyperbolic
sine of K. And so I
can write the whole thing
as hyperbolic cosine
1 plus hyperbolic tanh
of K sigma i sigma j.
OK?
So this tanh is really
same thing as here.
It's the high-temperature
expansion variable.
As K goes to 0 at
high temperature,
tanh K also goes to 0.
And it turns out that a much
nicer variable to expand
is this quantity tanh K. And so
that I don't have to repeat it
throughout, I will
give it the symbol t.
So small t stands not for
reduced temperature anymore,
but for hyperbolic tanh of K.
So my partition function
now, Z-- maybe I'll
go to another page.
So my partition function is a
sum over the 2 to the N binary
variables e to the K sigma i
sigma j sum over all bonds.
I can write that as a product of
these exponential factors over
[INAUDIBLE].
Each of these exponential
factors I can write as cosh K 1
plus t sigma i sigma j.
All the factors of cosh K
I will take to the outside.
So I will get cosh K
raised to the power
of the number of bonds
that I have in my lattice
because each bond
will contribute
one of these factors.
And then I have this sum over
sigma i product over bonds.
So this is the product
of 1 plus t factors.
So for each-- maybe
I'll do it over here.
So for each i, j, I have to
pick one of these factors.
I can either pick
1, nothing, or I
can pick a factor of
t sigma i sigma j.
OK?
So the first term
in this series--
since it's a series in powers of
t, the first term in the series
is to pick 1 everywhere.
The next term is to pick
one factor at some point.
But then when I
pick that factor,
that term in the series, I
have to sum over sigma i.
And when I sum over sigma
i, since this sigma i can
be plus or minus with equal
probability, it will give me 0.
OK?
So I cannot leave this
sigma i by itself.
So maybe I will pick
another higher-order term
in the series that has a t, a
sigma i that would make this
into a sigma i squared, and
then I will have a sigma K here.
OK?
Now, note it was kind of similar
to what I was doing here.
But here I could
pick as many bonds
as I like on as many factors of
K. Now what has happened here
is, effectively, I
have only two choices.
One choice is having
gone many, many times,
so summing all of the terms
that had 2, 4, et cetera.
That's what gives you the
cosh K. Or including something
like this, sum of
1, 3, 5, et cetera.
That's what gives you
tanh K. But the good thing
is that it's really
now a binary choice.
You either draw one line,
or you don't draw anything.
OK?
So again, your first choice is
to somehow complete the series
by drawing something like this.
And quite generically-- OK,
so after that has happened,
then this is sigma i squared.
This is sigma j squared.
These are all--
they have gone to 1.
And then you do the
sum over sigma i,
you will get a factor of 2.
So the answer is going to
be 2 to the number of sites,
N, cosh K to the power
of the number of bonds.
And then I would
have a series, which
is the sum over all graphs
with even number of bonds
per site like here.
So I either have 0 bond going
here, or I can have two bonds.
I could very well have
something like this, four bonds.
That doesn't violate anything.
So all I need to ensure
in order that sigma i does
not average to 0 is that I
have an even number per site.
And then the
contribution of the graph
is t to the number of
bonds in the graph.
And at this stage when I'm
calculating a partition
function, there is no
reason why I could not
have disconnected graphs.
For the partition function,
there is no problem.
Presumably, when I take the
log, the disconnected pieces
will go away.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where does the 2
to the N come from again?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So at each site, I have
to sum over sigma i.
So sigma i is either
minus 1 or plus 1.
What I'm doing is sum over
sigma i sigma i to some power.
And this is either
going to give me 2 or 0
depending on whether
P is even or P is odd.
All right?
OK?
So you can try to calculate
general terms for this series.
Let's say we go to
hypercubic lattice, which
is what we were doing before.
The number of bonds
per site is d.
So this, for the hypercubic
lattice, the number of bonds
will be dN.
You could do this calculation
for a triangular lattice.
You don't have to
stick with FCC lattice.
You don't have to stick with
these hypercubic lattices.
The first diagram that you can
create is always the square.
OK?
And in d dimensions, one leg
has a choice of d direction.
The next one would be d minus 1.
So this would be d d minus
1 over 2 t to the fourth.
But you could start it from
any site on the lattice
so you would have
something like this.
The next term that you
would have in the series
is something that involves,
let's say, six bonds.
So the next term
will be N t to the 6.
And I think I sometimes
convince myself
that the numerical factor
was something like this,
but doesn't matter.
You could calculate out of this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if
we have diagrams
of order of t squared, just
[INAUDIBLE] there and back?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Where would I get the
t squared from here?
OK?
So from this bond,
I have this factor,
1 plus t sigma i sigma j.
There is no t squared.
I would have had K squared,
K to the fourth, et cetera.
But I re-summed all of
them into hyperbolic cosine
and the hyperbolic sine.
So this--
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
taking this product
along all the bonds, you can
kind of go along the same bond.
PROFESSOR: We already
summed all of those things
together into this factor t.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
OK?
Yeah, it's good.
And that's why this tanh
is such a nice variable.
OK?
So there is actually
the nicer series
to work with in terms of
trying to extract exponent
is this high-temperature
series in terms
of these new
diagrams, et cetera.
But I'm not going to
be doing diagrammatics.
What I will be using this
high-temperature series
is the following.
One, to show that
in a few minutes
we can use it to exactly solve
the one-dimensional Ising model
and gain a physical
understanding of what's
happening, and 2, to
re-derive Gaussian model.
Turns out that there is a
close connection between all
of these loops that you
can draw on a lattice
through some kind of a path
integral way of thinking
about it with the
Gaussian model.
And that we actually will use as
a stepping stone towards where
we are really headed,
which is the exact solution
of the 2D Ising model.
OK?
So the 1D Ising model.
And actually, the method
is sufficiently powerful
that we can compare and
contrast two cases, one
when you have open chain.
So this is a system that is
composed of sites 1, 2, 3, 4,
N minus 1, N. On each one of
them I have an Ising variable.
And if I follow my nose, it's
a Z is 2 to the number of sites
cosh K to the power of
the number of bonds.
Actually, clearly with open
systems, the number of bonds
is 1 less than the
number of sites.
So I can be extremely precise.
It is N minus 1.
And then I have
to draw all graphs
that I can on this lattice that
have an even number of bonds
emanating from each site.
Find one.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Since you won't have
one, that stands.
So you can take the log of that.
You have this free
energy, whatever you like.
We can't.
1 is essentially not the zeroth
order term in this series.
Yes?
That was the question.
OK.
All right?
You can use the same
thing, same technology,
to calculate
spin-spin correlation.
So I pick spins m
and n on this chain.
Let's say this is spin m
here, and somewhere here I
put spin n.
And I want to know the
average of that quantity.
What am I supposed to do?
I'm supposed to sum over all
configurations with the weight
sigma i sigma i plus 1 product
over all-- well, actually,
we can be general with this.
Let's call it product over all
bonds, which, in this case,
are near neighbors,
sigma i sigma j.
That weight I have to
multiply by sigma m sigma n.
And then I have to divide
by the partition function
so that this is
appropriately weighted.
OK?
So I can do precisely the
same decomposition over here.
So I will have 2 to the N
cosh K to the number of bonds.
In fact, this I can
do in any dimensions.
It's not really what I would
have only in one dimension.
And the partition
function, you have seen,
is the sum over
all graphs, where
t to the number of bonds
in graph is called g.
Now I can do the same kind of
expansion that I did over here.
If I multiply with an
additional sigma m sigma n,
it is just like I
have already a sigma m
and a sigma n somewhere.
And when I sum
over sigmas, I have
to make sure that these
things don't average to 0.
So what I need to
do is to draw graphs
that have an even
number at all sites
and an odd number
at these two sites.
All right?
So this is sum over g with
even number except on m and n,
where you have to
have an odd number,
and t is subset of graphs.
OK?
So if I do this
for the 1D model,
sigma m sigma n, I have to draw
graphs that have, essentially,
an odd number.
Essentially, sigma
m and sigma n should
be the origins or ends of lines.
And clearly, I can draw a
graph that connects these two.
And so what I will get is
t to the number of steps
that I have to make
between the two of them.
The rest of the it is going to
be the same, 2 to the N cosh K
to the N minus 1 in the
numerator and denominator,
they cancel each other.
OK?
So you can see
explicitly that this
is a function that decays
since t is less than 1
as I go further and further out.
And that it is a
pure exponential.
So you remember that we said in
general you would have a power
law line in front that would
have an exponent [? theta. ?]
And when we did r of
g, I told you, well,
[? theta ?] came out to be
1 such that you have pure
exponential.
Well, here is the proof.
And furthermore, from this
we see that c is minus 1
over log of the
hyperbolic tanh of K.
And if you expand
that, you will find
that as K goes to
infinity, it has
precisely that e to
the 2K divergence
that we had calculated.
So you can see that
calculating things
using this graphical
method is very simple.
And essentially, the
interpretation of t
is that it is the fidelity
with which information
goes from one site
to the next site.
And so the further
away you go every time,
you lose a factor
of t in how sure
you are about the nature
of where you started with.
And so as you go further, you
have this exponential decay.
OK?
And the other thing that
we can do at no cost
is periodic boundary conditions.
So we take, again,
our spins 1, 2, 3,
except that we then bend it
such that the last one comes
and gets connected
to the first one.
OK?
So what's the partition
function in this case?
It is 2 to the N.
The number of
bonds, in this case,
is exactly the same as
the number of sites.
It's one more than
before, so I get
to cosh K raised to the power
of N. And then is it just one?
There is one thing that
goes all the way around,
so I have 1 plus t to the N. So
this is an exponentially small
correction as we go
further and further out.
You can kind of regard that as
some finite-size interaction.
I can similarly calculate sigma
m sigma n, the expectation
value.
OK?
And in the denominator
from the partition
function, I have this factor
of 1 to the t to the N.
In the numerator,
again, you should
be able to see two graphs.
We can either connect this way
or we can connect that way.
So you'll have t to
the power of n minus m,
but you don't know which angle
is the smaller one, so you'll
have to also include
the other one.
OK?
So again, if we take N
to infinity and these two
sufficiently close,
you can see that all
of these finite-size
effects, boundary effects,
et cetera disappear.
But this is, again,
a toy model in which
to think about what the effects
of boundaries is, et cetera.
You can see how nicely
this graphical method
can enable you to calculate
things very rapidly.
We'll see that, again, it
provides the right tools
conceptually to think about what
happens in higher dimensions.